knowing everything about arcad is all
well and good but if you don't have good
title blocks to go with it your drawings
aren't going to look professional
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we're trying a little bit of a
different angle a little bit of a
different setup for the start of this
video so feel free to let me know what
you think if you're new to this channel
firstly thank you so much for joining me
on this channel we talk all things
technology and architecture today we're
diving into arcade25 and exactly how you
can set up your title blocks these title
blocks will be available for download in
the links below so if you want to grab a
copy of all of the templates that i
create we're going to go through one
step by step today but i'm going to make
every single page size available for you
guys in the links below that means
everything from an a3 all the way up to
an a1 will be available in both
landscape and portrait modes so if you
don't want to go and spend all your time
creating these setting them up they will
be down below for you to download anyway
enough for my rambling let's turn around
to these two screens and get into
today's video okay as always we start
with the australian select template use
whatever template you have available to
you guys this is just the template
available to me and in my region so
we're just going to click new template
and allow arcad to load now to create a
new title block in archicad 25 or any
other archicad in particular actually
what we're going to do is come across to
our layout book our layout book holds
all of our drawings and all of our
details we're going to go all the way to
the bottom to this masters template so
we're going to open up our masters and
we're going to see a1 cover a1 landscape
and all sorts of different information
available on this masters layout
so if we drop down our a1 cover block we
can double click on a1
and you'll see it gives you the generic
title block
from arcade 25 it is very very basic
it's very generic
it has some details that are important
but overall it's nothing special nothing
flash what you'll also notice is that
the bleed markers around the actual
border are incredibly thick more so for
stapling on this side than anything else
but it's up to you guys how you want to
set it up personally i set it up for a
digital presentation and a digital
format more so than a hard copy physical
print because more often than not these
aren't getting stapled these aren't
getting stuck and there's a lot of
information not being lost on this side
of the page anyway so i set up my bleeds
accordingly so to change these bleeds
we're going to go up to document we're
going to come all the way down to layout
book and we are going to change our
master layout settings so as you can see
we have some pretty significant margins
on our a1 metric title block what i'm
going to do is simply reduce all of
these to five millimeters because that
is a traditional a1 printer's bleed
setup if you know what your printer's
bleed settings are i highly recommend
that you come in and change this
specifically for your printer so you
aren't losing any information you can
usually get this bleed information
directly from the printer manufacturer
so do have a quick look at what your
printer is set up to but five is a
pretty safe border overall so now by
clicking ok we see that purple line
move all the way out to our edge itself
so then we have a five millimeter bleed
that is basically non-printable area and
we have our purple line that dictates
what's safe to print in that's always a
very very useful bit of information to
use what i'm going to do here is simply
select this title block in itself click
control d and just move it out the way
for now we can reference back to it a
little bit later but overall we're not
really going to be touching this too
much next what we're going to do is
simply scroll down here in the document
element settings and select our polyline
i am simply going to draw one square
around this bleedable area so we're
going to select our square we're going
to make sure we have full black we
probably don't need it to be too thick
so
0.13 is okay i'd prefer to point one but
it's not really a big deal so what we're
going to do is zoom in all the way to
our five mil print bleed and make sure
we select that corner as
absolutely best as we can which seems to
be an incredibly challenging task but
we'll leave it at that that's okay we
can drag it out a little bit later we're
going to come back up to our other side
finish off that square
and zoom out so what we see now is an
actual physical hard boundary printed on
the box
this isn't necessarily required but i
really like to set a physical boundary
on the drawing board so if anything is
printed and anything is lost on a
different printer you know where
information has been lost that's just a
personal thing what i then like to do is
offset all the edges another five
millimeters to give us a very safe bleed
area this also gives us a really good
place to put some copyright information
which we're going to get to right now so
basically what we do is we come down to
the bottom left hand corner and we
activate our text tool so we start by
simply opening up a text box
changing this to about 1.8 millimeters
and typing in our company information
now we're simply going to do is insert a
symbol and we're going to find the
copyright symbol which is just here
we're going to select that and we're
going to select an insert so copy close
paste next we're going to continue on by
typing in our company information so
we're gonna go
company the year it was founded so let's
go 2021 and our website then we're all
simply just going to click control e
rotate this 90 degrees and place our
company website in the bottom left hand
corner directly in line with this bleed
marker that we've made so now we have
the basic starting point of our template
this is the corner that is basically not
going to change throughout the entire
process i am going to go and create
horizontal and vertical templates so if
you do want to download them you can
there will be a link just down below
i'll make sure it's the first one for
you guys but moving on what we're simply
going to do now is copy this polyline
settings and we're going to draw a box
all the way across
i'm going to make this about 40
millimeters high which is relatively
small but gives you enough room
basically to play with all the
information that you need now the next
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to simply annotate the area of
where things should go so company logo
will go here i'm just gonna make that
five i'm gonna make it bold stands out
so you know you can place your company
logo your personal logo right there next
i like to get this simple line tool draw
an easy line and offset that five mil
either side so if we offset that five
mil it gives us a nice clean break
between the company logo and the next
information about the company so now
we're going to make sure this line is
offset perfectly from here so let's go
90 minus which means it's perfectly 90
millimeters away from that line and next
we're simply going to drag that line 120
millimeters across and drag it all the
way top to bottom to finish off that bot
now basically in this section here we're
going to input all of our company
information so these bits aren't
automated you will have to do a little
bit of work here to be able to bring it
up to scratch for yourself
because i can't guess all your companies
but i can try give you enough
information to start with so what we're
going to do here is we're going to shift
our information across a little bit and
we're going to start inputting our
company information here now i have left
this space quite open and quite blank
you can see it seems a little bit empty
but that's because company addresses
telephone numbers email addresses tend
to go for quite a large amount of space
and if you put your company name in full
with the llc the pty ltd whatever it is
around the world it means it basically
just extends the length of that name
quite significantly so i always leave
plenty of room for information on this
side here next we're simply going to
drag this line across another 75
millimeters and leave this as a blank
space this element here is basically
where your registration information goes
your stamp of approval grows
or anything that basically acknowledges
your ability to do your work so in
australia it's an architect's
association membership badge
it could be any sort of recognition
awards things you've won so it's
basically a recognition logo now we
start moving in to the autonomous areas
of this title block where you basically
have to set and forget
what we're going to set it up as is if
you go into file
info project info this is basically
where you're going to adjust the
information to automatically adjust it
in the title block so we'll get to that
at the end but for now all i'm going to
do is input that information and then
show you guys how to change it the first
thing we're going to do is input our
project address which means we need
another area to be basically create that
box so i'm going to expand that another
100 millimeters to be able to start
inputting out information now simply all
i'm going to do is change this to
project and
delete all that and then i'm also going
to copy paste that to project
address just a quick interlude guys
before we jump any further with this
tutorial if you are lost getting stuck
or struggling with any of my tutorials
make sure you check out the discord link
below and join the discord community
chat it is slowly growing into a great
community where people are sharing their
experiences talking about these
tutorials and
problem solving all sorts of arcade
related questions so if you're looking
for a community where you can simply
join 100 for free the discord link is
below if you want a copy of any of my
archicad files that i've created for
youtube for these tutorials there is a
patreon link below that discord link
that basically gives you all access
to that discord chat which means there's
basically one chat in that discord that
is private but every other chat is 100
free so if either of those things
interest you make sure you check out the
links below there is also a fantastic
checklist available on my website if
you're doing sketch design or
construction drawings and don't know
where to start don't know what
information needs to go on even if
you're an experienced architect these
checklists are fantastic to make sure
your drawings are going out correct now
what we're going to do is actually
introduce some automated text this is a
relatively simple process but it means
that we input automatic text blocks and
it updates as it sees fit so as you
update that project information it'll
automatically update anything we do here
to do that it's very simple you
literally come into insert auto text and
you look for what you're actually
looking for so in project details we're
probably going to want our project
description right there
so i'm also going to change that to two
millimeters not bold and put another
space in
then we're going to come across to our
project address and repeat the same step
so insert auto text site address one so
if you double click on that we have our
site address one and
we are done so basically what we've just
created
is our first set of autonomous text i'm
going to drag that text box out all the
way so you can basically use that text
box
to your full ability to the full length
of that without having to worry about it
dropping and changing now i keep the
project and the project address in one
specific area because it describes what
the project is is it a one-story
two-story three-story is it commercial
etc and the project address is all
relevant to that box so now if i show
you how to change this if we go to file
info project info
we're going to see that project
description let's call it a proposed
townhouse
and if we scroll down we're gonna see
our site address come up a little bit
further down below full site address if
we open up this
it'll be in address one so we're
basically gonna fill out this entire box
let's go 10
random street
in australia
if we click ok and then i press ok once
more you'll see those two automatically
populate
now this is fantastic because it means
you don't have to go through every
single page to update it when you do a
project i will quickly come back into
info project info and go delete and
change this to update here so you guys
are aware of what you need to update i
might simply as well just to make this
basically foolproof for anybody who
hasn't watched the video in its entirety
go now you guys know you have to go to
file info project info to be able to
update that information where you see
fit now our next box again we are going
to stretch that out another 100
millimeters to make sure it's identical
to this we are going to copy and paste
that 100 millimeters across and we're
going to start putting in our client
information
so this this box here is all about our
client it's all about their information
so we know who this project is for who
it belongs to and that we always have
relevant information so we're going to
delete all of that and go back to our
auto text minimize these come to our
client contact details i'm going to
input the client's full name here so
that's all i'm really going to update
i'm going to cancel out of that
and align our information if you want to
put more information into that area
there specifically about the client
potentially their contact details or
anything like that you can i don't
recommend it usually names are enough
you don't really want to be giving away
too much private confidential client
information so simply first name last
name is more than enough information you
have to give next we're going to
replicate that once more we're going to
make this box a little bit bigger so
we're going to go to 150 millimeters
across
leaving us a simple area at the end that
we're almost finished
so now this area is basically all about
our revisions all about our information
of the actual project and why we have
implemented it into the project what the
revision is being revised for is it for
client information is it for
construction is it for the council who
is it for what is it for so this is a
very important
section and hence why i've made it one
of the largest and last but not least
i'm actually going to drag this a little
bit back and another 15 mil and i'm
probably going to put some
information here of who it's going to
so issued two there we have our basic
information it is very
bold it is very easy to read it's very
to see and now we're going to populate
the rest with basically autonomous text
again
now arcad doesn't have this inputted how
i specifically like it so i'm going to
update the actual
automatic text inside the project info
so if we go file info project info
scroll down we're going to see that we
have a list of our actual colleagues
that we work with like all our engineers
and planets information isn't really too
important for me on the document so i
tend to get rid of it
we'll start by taking out the certifier
and changing this to revision and we're
basically going to follow our
instructions below date now i'm simply
going to put a 1 at the front of
everything so that we can differentiate
the two in this column here and then
we're gonna repeat that same step to rev
two
date two so that we have two basically
rows of the same information i don't
need a civil engineer i'm simply going
to remove them for now so we have a very
simple basically procedure to follow i'm
now going to click ok come back into my
revision text go auto text go site
details go project details and go rev1
so now we can go back into this change
that to a two
millimeter text and it doesn't need to
be bold that'll simply be a b c
0 0 whatever you want it to be and then
i'm going to replicate that once below
and change that to rev2 clicking ok
and
following that basically procedure all
the way across to the end of this box
now this is the critical part of this
title block where all the information is
stored about your project about the job
about the page numbers and basically
where you reference i personally like to
leave it in the bottom right hand corner
because as you're flicking through pages
you're looking at that bottom right hand
corner flicking over the page
traditionally you might be flicking the
other way but considering that most the
world is right-handed we flick right to
left
you can flip this entire title block
around if you see that as different in
your personal circumstances
but for me personally i do like to keep
all that information on the right hand
side of the screen now to create this we
basically need to break this up into one
two three four sections somewhat evenly
distributed so what we're going to do is
we're going to create a 20 millimeter
20 millimeter and then we're simply
going to break those two in half
and call it
uh
73 mils in between so next step is to
simply break these two small boxes in
half and to also break the large box at
the end in half as well so we split that
in half now we have some sort of
predominant information that we're
talking about our critical information
of the project let's drag our main
element across here and it's going to be
drawn by
is our first
element that is important that doesn't
really need to be bold or in extremely
large text so it's simply going to drag
that down and make it a little bit
smaller
so we actually fit inside our text box
i'm actually just going to delete the by
bit to make sure it's quite clean quite
minimal and i'm going to then put
checked below as well so we know these
two are very important who drew it and
who checked it next when was this
drawing actually issued so the date of
when it was drawn
and finally the scale of the actual
drawing itself next we're going to have
some critical information like the
drawing number or the page number
whatever you wish to actually call this
box i like to call it drawing number
instead of page number to not confuse
people and finally we are going to have
our page size as well now page size is
critical that we have this information
on there because it isn't to scale
unless it is printed to the actual page
size finally we're going to have over
here in our last two boxes our internal
job number and we're also going to have
our stage or revision now all these
aren't critical information they don't
need to be bold but they are internally
important so if anybody's referencing it
they know where to go now again archive
doesn't have all the details in its
automated text to be able to input this
information here so we're going to have
to come back up to our project info and
start changing some elements in here i
do scroll down to the contact details
information panel because that's really
all about the contact information so
we're going to start by simply changing
a few bits and pieces you'll see that
the drawn by is already available to us
so we're going to just change that to
drawn so it's capital we know exactly
what it is i'm going to change that to
checked we have our project id which
will be update required that is our
internal job number and also our project
number which is going to be our stage or
revision so if i click ok now i can come
into drawn
and start updating some autonomous text
so then again if we come down to contact
details we can see our drawn is here and
i'm going to copy that further down
replace that with the checked buy box
now these are usually just initials
they're not really too important so you
just scroll down and we're going to come
to our drawn and checked checked by dt
drawn by dt that's not usually how would
be you'd have a separate signature or a
separate bit of information for each
checked and drawn candidate they're not
meant to be the same in principle the
date in itself will be the today's date
the current bit of information so if we
just type in date and change that to
system we will get the short system date
of today's date when this information
and when this drawing was exported now i
like to keep that as shown guys because
you can have multiple drawings on one
page they could be multiple scales so
you don't want to have to go update that
every single time it's just a huge pain
so i just leave it as shown and it isn't
automatic at all next we're simply just
going to have our layer id here so if
for example i scroll up to
any of these pages let's go a001 floor
plan right click that layout settings
change to a1 cover page and click ok i
will just quickly point out that i did
delete that other template that we've
created you'll see it gives you page
a101 exactly what page it is we can
introduce page of 115 or whatever we
want but because this hasn't been set up
properly in the arcade select template
that isn't actually too easy to do in
this situation so i'm just going to keep
it as a 101 and automatically update
that page number
now coming back to our title page what
i'm actually going to do is just delete
that for now we don't need to reference
it we're not worried about it at all
we're going to start inputting these
final two bits of information now
because these are critically important
we're gonna make sure they are quite
large this for us is the internal job
number so we're gonna insert
job number which is project id
and lastly stage and revision which is
for us
our project number so if we click ok
there so now if we come back into file
info project info let's say we change
our project id to
i don't know
zt001 and our project number to sketch 0
1 you'll see that change automatically
as we require it so i'm just going to
change that back to update and back to
update as well so now you know you have
to update these this layer id is
automated you don't have to touch it
that's why it doesn't say update these
are probably a little bit too big for my
liking i'm probably going to scale them
back down to about a four
from a six probably way too big and
that's basically it guys that is the
title block completed that's all the
information you need to show on this
title block we have all our company
information we have a recognition
company logo we have all our project and
our client details our revision and our
information and all our internal
information as well you can go massively
overboard with a title block it can have
way way way too much information on it
but for the purposes of this we don't
really need to over complicate it you
can have a cover page with a whole bunch
of notes like you saw previously below
in that title block it had the example
of the builders notes and the clients
notes and all those things you can have
a dedicated page for that because
that is not enough information to cover
anybody so we will be probably having a
dedicated page somewhere an information
package and we'll also have a dedicated
cover page as well however this is going
to be the main bit of information shown
on all of your title blocks anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
the video i hope you learned something
new and informative as always remember
to check out the links down below
there's all sorts of great stuff from
checklists to templates to these title
blocks that we've created today as well
as a fantastic discord community that
i'd love for you to be a part of if you
wouldn't mind smashing that like button
to help this video with the youtube
algorithm and if you enjoyed the content
you saw today smash that subscribe
button along with the notification bell
to be notified every monday of when a
new tutorial comes out or a new
architecture related informative
technological video is launched this
channel is ever changing ever growing
and forever pushing to make sure that
you guys that community that supports me
gets the content they're looking for so
if you want to see anything drop it in
the discord chat drop it in the comments
below and i will try to make it happen
for you but anyway that is all from me
today guys i will see you next monday